can we just talk about something serious
for a minute we have this story from
live science us government reported
proposed nuking the moon newly released
documents reveal james why is the moon
flat tim tim us government report
discuss his plan to nuke the moon
my name is brandon spector in our latest
report the u.s government has proposed
nuking the moon newly released documents
reveal
this just ends the moon
so
this is a real story what are they
trying to find out if it's hollow or how
hollow
hold
wait u.s government report proposed but
they proposed nuking the moon is this
like the big ask you know um who
proposes
version of what you want so you could
end up with something less extreme
i actually think if i were to run for
office it would be in the position that
we should nuke the moon so tell me more
about this is this dude what why are
they doing this they say include nearly
600 pages of reports proposals contracts
and meeting notes reveal some stranger
priorities a department department of
defense program that ran from 07 to 12
but only became known to the public in
2017 blah blah blah
they say new documents suggest they were
more than investigating the entire cache
of documents yadda yadda perhaps most
intriguing look how long oh okay yeah so
so the document here says let me read
this the various advanced technologies
the collections include transversable
wormholes stargates and negative energy
high frequency gravitational wave
communication warp drive dark energy and
the manipulation of extra dimensions and
many other topics that will sound
familiar to fans of science hold on i
actually i have this so so the proposal
says uh people are talking about cousin
marriages uh it's time to just end it
all let's nuke the moon honestly there
you go yeah that's it
the moon let's go deeper trans
dimensional waves is that what they said
so they're doing like i saw something
about pregnancy down there what is so is
that where the aliens made people
pregnant
yeah unaccounted for pregnancies did you
guys hear about this they say the latest
foia document dump arrived just three
weeks after british tabloid the sun
obtained more than fifteen hundred pages
related to alleged ufo encounters
catalogued by the aatip
including among the documents was a
report on the alleged biological effects
of ufo encounters on humans the report
listed paralysis apparent abduction and
unaccounted for pregnancy the side
effect yeah right they just didn't want
to talk about it they're like oh by the
way i think i had sex it's like some
woman she did on her husband and then
she comes back and he's like
how did you get pregnant she goes aliens
that explains it i just pulled up that
they look like they were trying to nuke
the moon to tunnel through it why would
they want to tunnel through the moon i
don't build spaces
why do you assume that you can just say
anything no matter how ridiculous and
i'm just going to have your background
do you not think aliens are demons
that's beside the point
oh yeah so like a lot a lot of people
are actually reporting on the release of
these documents we have this from new
york post as well
crowd control heat weapons
killer space lasers all right you know
i'm listening what is this it mirrors an
energy source to fire lasers atmospheric
absorption scattering and it's blowing
up a missile or something
well maybe they're doing a bit oh so
they can spray a laser into the
atmosphere and then make it spread out
when it hits the atmosphere no it's
focusing it's all the lights are
pointing together so the single point
you know what happened someone got drunk
at nasa and forgot to write up their
proposal and they're just like i'll
write something so yeah i think wild
that no one will question it it's like
the craziest cultists are in the
government i mean they have all the
power in the world literally they're the
most powerful people in the world and
like who knows if they're dropping acid
and taking mushrooms and like what they
really probably believe it's real i mean
a lot of people do it micro dosed and uh
went a little over and then nobody's
planned you know you know what happens
we're victims of our own storytelling so
you know what happens on youtube is
uh we'll use phrases as an example oh
yes is it my opinion on furries i think
the reason people identify as furry is
because they grew up watching looney
tunes and anthropomorphized animals so
they want to then when they're older
they dress like cartoon animals i
thought about this because i realized
like you see these memes about furries
and i'm like they're not dressing like
animals they're singing like bugs bunny
and like the big white hands and
everything sometimes they're dressing to
hook up with lola bunny it's the amount
of rifle that so sola made into
depending on who you asked we've had
people super chat and say it's not about
just like sex it's about being it and
being that thing and i'm like yeah it's
because they watched anthropomorphized
animals as kids if that idea didn't
exist they wouldn't have it so what
happens is you'll get someone you know
1947 and the government's like if they
find out about our nuclear you know
programs it's going to be bad so just
lie and say it's aliens so turn them
into furries so they don't know anything
so then the media reports aliens some
little kid reads and goes whoa aliens
grows up believing that story and then
enlists to join the ufo program
genuinely believing it was aliens the
whole time and they're being lied to and
then they tell people i've seen some
weird stuff and i think it's aliens that
kid then grows up being like whoa aliens
are real the guy from nasa told me i
better go work there and they just it
perpetuates a monster bob lazar is
notoriously made publicly humiliate
humiliated basically publicly by saying
zeta reticuli and the aliens he saw and
i think that was just red herrings that
they fed him because they're like this
guy they tell their scientists
so if they ever go rogue then they're
going to look like idiots if they
actually knew they were working on
drones he said he saw a little green man
yeah they probably had a stuffed
literally a stuffed animal sitting in it
they wanted at a carnival and they're
like they put it in the shade they
changed the story later to be like it
was a puppet yeah
translating them yeah exactly yeah no
i don't doubt the drone program though
tesla was working on some cool
technology in the it was the fbi that
went in there and took it nuke the moon
do we have to i think we want to nuke
the poles on mars mount rushmore on the
moon yes mount rushmore on the moon
trump's face on the moon quite frankly i
think it looks better stay seated
okay all right let's compromise we nuke
the moon
to make an engraving of trump's face
there we go oh i wonder what media
matters is going to say
they're going to be like far right calls
for nuking the moon to create a portrait
of trump
yes and they're right they're absolutely
correct
yes and if you would like to help us on
our mission become members at
timcast.com that's the only way we'll do
it we should
crowdfund i mean
yeah can we can we crowdfund the new the
moon yeah there might be laws against
that i think that would probably not be
legal i don't know you can't nuke other
countries but the moon isn't a country
yeah should it be and and you know what
happened
all of the flat earther people who think
the moon is a space station is spying on
us would be like yes i'll give you money
please
do it did you guys ever hear about that
guy who built his own rocket ship and i
think he died
huh yes sounds about right i don't hear
about this
it was like he was like a flat earther
or something did he
yeah oh my god wait no i i think i don't
i don't know it's that guy in homemade
rocks
well there's a lot of guys who made
homemade rockets but there was oh i
think this might be it yeah
no no this was just a daredevil i don't
want to disparage this guy uh he was
just trying to do it but i read a story
about a guy who like made his own rocket
because he wanted to prove the earth was
flat or something and then he like he
died oh my gosh
flat earthers are funny physics is
pretty cool
a guy made a rocket and died physics is
cool i mean it's he thought the earth
was flat i'd say go with the physics on
this one guys
it's around it looks very spherical from
space and and through measurements have
you ever been to
horizonal uh longitude and latitude have
you ever been to space
uh not not not consciously but not now
how do you know then
uh i've seen pictures pictures how do
you know they're not just fish
i've seen streaming live from the iss
fisheye lens you think that they're
they're not actually streaming live from
the audiences around bro but this is the
point that they make
antarctica can you yeah have you ever
are you really sure you're you
how do you know what you are tim like
come on guys at some point physics is
real
right that's not my point my point is
when you talk to flat earthers no matter
what you say they have an answer
yeah you're like i don't talk to them
no i do you don't want to be debunked i
don't too scared you're right you're
terrified of debating them
like tens of thousands of years ago they
thought it was really flat they thought
it was on the back of a turtle or
something no different cultures
on the back of it they were like if you
sail too far west you're going to fall
off the earth so they didn't and then no
i don't think that's true the the story
is that uh eratosthenes
accurately the circumference of the
earth by measuring shadows at two
different points at the same time or
something yeah and it's funny because
the flat earthers are like how was he
able to coordinate that how did he do it
if if he didn't have a cell phone and
i'm like oh geez people couldn't
communicate over long distances back
then like fire didn't exist smoke didn't
exist and general timing didn't exist
it's just ridiculous yeah he he had two
towers he measured their shadows and
said here's here's how you know how big
the thing is on we're on and then
apparently we never thought the earth
was flat because as soon as we
discovered seafaring you'd see things go
over the higher over the horizon boats
would appear to go down as they got to
the you know to the horizon too far away
and so they were like run a big ball
yeah that must have been super ancient
before they even realize like the
horizon bends when you look out at the
ocean that's the turtle shell you guys
are gonna be so mad when you find out
we're on a turtle like can you imagine
like you died
what is this what is the turtle on i
would be scared
what is the turtle on it are you joking
don't say lsd
because it's obvious
yeah don't tell me this turtle's on dmt
what's sustaining this turtle
it's called it's called the world
and it's the energy you're curious of
our colleagues
did you not it's a flat earth attached
to it
where does that come from is it an
elephant on a turtle is this
a hindu i like them i like how the moon
is still uh a sphere so is the sun
yeah don't ask me i don't know oh yeah
it's hindu mythology and then we enter
the kali yuga and the world turtle flips
around or something is that what
happened i don't know dude
if i died and then like
could see the the world turtle i'd be
stoked i got a pleasure it was a turtle
if you guys could either watch the
formation of the of the solar system and
as fast as you wanted just to see it
happen or have a conversation with jesus
what would you pick jesus i talked to
jesus yeah he would tell me
yeah
jesus would tell you all about all of
that stuff i would watch the universe
personally
you what would you you said jesus yeah
but tell you what though exactly i don't
know i feel like he was just a guy that
got taken out of context well i guess it
depends on what context are you talking
to jesus like right now yeah if you
could just have a real conversation with
him
right now so basically what you're
saying so basically what you're saying
is you're not talking about conventional
prayer you're saying you ask god any
question he gives you the answer yeah
he's not going to go back to like three
like you don't like guaranteed it's
going to be yeah if you're going to go
to three
like it might make christians now no
longer christian if they meet him
they're like whoa he actually is just a
guy like if you could go back to 3ad and
sit down with the dude and talk to him
or whatever when he was 24 or something
yeah i'm sure a bunch of uh saints got
persecuted boiled and hung for just a
guy i heard that there was a there's a
book about it actually that the roman
emperor at the time and a bunch of uh
roman oligarchs made christianity to
disempower the jews because they had too
much power
but i think that is such a wild
scholar
to get to your actual question you have
to have
it's like
would you would you want to talk to a
guy people think is god or would would
you want to see the universe form those
are two very very distinct questions
well obviously i would like to have a
supernatural experience watching the
formation of the universe but if the
premise is that jesus is god i'd be like
i'd much rather talk to jesus well
there's no premise
that's why i just asked the question
blindly like that so you need to ask the
question so you have different belief
structures obviously
that's why i'm interested for people who
believe jesus is god they'd be like i
would like to talk to jesus yeah i would
think i would think for you it was just
a guy it's like well that's a different
question i don't know if he's just a guy
but i'd still rather watch the universe
get formed because i don't know if
there's a binary star collision or not
okay but okay so you watch the universe
get formed and you don't really get too
many answers okay great it formed
somehow science
whatever turtle giant turtle
but you get to talk to jesus and you get
to find out the fate of your soul in the
afterlife like why wouldn't you well i
want to find out
a z pinch that caused the sun to like
overcharge itself and then spit out all
this matter or if it was a binary star
collision that caused it to argue that
it's more important than your eternity
yeah but what's the guarantee that jesus
would tell you about your attorney i
actually totally talked
i don't know i think about the universe
forming too i wish i could go with you i
kind of think that
god or jesus would say you know you need
to live your experience and live your
life and and
well now that's my point is we can pray
now and ask god questions now yeah yeah
it's true but i think you get an answer
through your own human filter
i think sometimes i think people can
absolutely pray and deceive themselves
and think they're hearing from god
they're just hearing from themselves can
i just choose to believe we're on the
back of a turtle yeah i mean tim you
look you can see that's called psychosis
this just in the universe has been
discovered to be on the back of a turtle
more at nine o'clock i guess what is
evidence really you know just agreed
upon
information oh it's held up by elephants
yes yeah elephants on the turtles back
that is crazy like why somebody was
smoking when they thought of that
they're like you know the earth it's
flat no like it is yeah held up by
elephants
where what are the elephants on here it
is the turtle this book that i mentioned
is called creating christ how roman
emperors invented christianity
uh
and when i heard that it was just like a
couple weeks ago someone listened to me
i thought that is not far out of the
question can we it is very unfavorable
historically can we can we get a little
guy guys can we get a vote um all in
favor of giving ian title of blasphemer
well think think about it logically
everybody
the jews at the time had massive
political power and the romans were
really authoritarian so i could see they
would stop it nothing you could make
anything sanhedrin and you know the
roman government to destroy what they
had created for the purpose of getting
rid of the power of i don't know
anything about the same hebrew and what
did it get created the powerful jews in
rome from my understanding
just using big words like bosh
why would they destroy what they created
and allow the group they were trying to
destroy through it to do that as well um
i would imagine because generations
later and the people were changed at
that point maybe people were like wow
what have we done let's rectify or stuff
like that maybe i don't know much about
what you had mentioned what year was you
know what years it all happened this
reports that it was like in 70 a.d or
something that they got
that they did this i'm really i think i
think
it we i don't know if we can really
serve these conversations
very well without
scholars
yeah but that's also what i'm saying is
i'm not just talking about catholic
scholars the scholarly consensus
atheistic or otherwise is that jesus
christ
existed right i believe he exists but
there there are no scholars i mean
mythicism is a fringe position mythicism
is the the belief that jesus didn't
exist he's completely fictional that is
the
slim minority view yeah i don't think
that i think i would imagine he existed
but that could they call it the roman
they call it the roman catholic church
it's roman dude
rome was the empire like thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there